Here's the thing that makes life so interesting.
The theory of evolution claims, "Only the strong shall survive."
Maybe so, maybe so.
But the theory of competition says,...
..."Just because they're the strong doesn't mean they can't get their asses kicked."
That's right.
See, what every long shot, come-from-behind underdog will tell you is this:...
...the other guy may in fact be the favorite, the odds may be stacked against you, fair enough.
But what the odds don't know is this isn't a math test.
This is a completely different kind of test,...
...one where passion has a funny way of trumping logic.
So before you step up to the starting line, before the whistle blows,...
...and the clocks start ticking, just remember: out here the results don't always add up.
No matter what the stats may say and the experts may think...
...and the commentators may have predicted,...
...when the race is on, all bets are off.
Don't be surprised if somebody decides to flip the script and take a pass on yelling "Uncle!"
And then suddenly, as the old saying goes, "We've got ourselves a game."